hey there's a bit of a sticky or
technically non-sticky situation at
Speedways all over the country and that
does include our Las Vegas Motor
Speedway here's the deal they're running
out of glue but we're not talking about
Elmer's Glue the racers call it traction
compound that sticky black stuff that
kind of glazes over drag strips
because it's going to keep the car
grounded it's going to make sure that
it's under control at all times give it
more grip to the to the track itself to
where it's going straight rather than
kind of veering off right or left
yeah you don't want that so shortages
from the pandemic have cut into the
nation's glue Supply because of that Las
Vegas Motor Speedway said they had to
cancel a bunch of events that they tried
and tried to find more glue now somebody
did save the Thanksgiving bracket
Nationals at the strip that's November
23rd to the 27th but other races like
the Summit Racing Equipment midnight
Mayhem December 2nd the test in tune
December 3rd those are off for now no
word when that glue shortage might and
Las Vegas Motor Speedway warning other
races at the drag strip may be up in the
air too as